Social Security should not be keeping
Americans afloat for 30 years of their
life well that's not the Private
Industry isn't it why is it a failure
for the Private Industry well I mean
social security has maintained it the
the idea that we're leaning on the
government uh uh um stool because the
other two have failed that's what that's
okay isn't it a private business is that
a function of just the average person
understanding how money works and saving
money investing and doing it properly
versus the government or constitution of
of the country lives paycheck to
paycheck how are they supposed to save
this money
well how are they spending their money I
guess is the biggest question how many
people have credit card debt how many
people you just said when you took out a
mortgage you said I'm an actor what was
the rate you're like I don't even know
you should know well I was making so
much money that I don't get how much
money Sam you should know what your
mortgage rate is
foreign
[Music]